hard-working people are up against a
small group that holds far too much
power not just in our economy but also
in our democracy Elizabeth Warren likes
to say she's a champion of the little
guy but she recently announced a major
policy proposal that would provide more
than a trillion dollars in aid that
would disproportionately benefit the
relatively well-off and well-connected
we are going to roll back student loan
debt for about 95 percent of students
who have debt
the idea is to eliminate debt up to
$50,000 for people with household
incomes under $100,000 and more limited
debt cancellation for households making
between one hundred thousand and two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a
year by her own estimates the full plan
which also includes funds for Pell
grants and historically black colleges
would cost about 1.25 trillion dollars
but the nature of college attendance and
student loans means that Warren's loan
forgiveness plan is actually a massive
giveaway to the relatively well-off only
about a third of people over 25 have a
college degree making them a
comparatively elite group whose elite
status is reinforced by among other
things the connections they make while
at college college graduates earn about
1 million dollars more during their
lifetimes to non-college graduates
according to a Georgetown University
study a separate study from pew found
that college graduates typically earn
about seventeen thousand five hundred
dollars more annually than people who
only have high school degrees college
graduates aren't for the most part super
rich but generally speaking they are far
more comfortable than the majority who
lack such degrees and while many of the
people who would benefit from the plan
currently have modest incomes that's
partly because many of them are young
people with relatively high future
earnings potential this is a plan that
would spend taxpayer money to benefit
them Warren's defenders might respond
that it's still a downward transfer
since the whole thing will be paid for
by a new tax on the super wealth there
are however a few problems with using a
wealth tax as a financing mechanism the
first is that the tax might not be
constitutional and even if it is another
problem is that it's likely to raise far
less money than projected that's why
most countries that have tried wealth
taxes over the last two decades have
abandoned them the third as Washington
examiner's Phil Kline points out is that
Warren has suggested that this same
wealth tax could also be used to help
pay
a whole slew of other progressive policy
ideas those include Medicare for all the
green New Deal and subsidized child care
which altogether would cost tens of
trillions of dollars far more than even
the most generous wealth tax would raise
I'm tired of Washington that works for
the rich and the powerful
I want a Washington that works for the
rest of America that's why I'm in this
fight ultimately what Warren wants to do
is tax the wealthy to help them merely
well off rather than prioritize programs
that help the truly need Warren isn't
helping the little guy she's helping
folks already on top stay that way
[Music]